الى تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
حيث قتل ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل في هجوم
روسي بثمان طائرات مسيره استهدف مدينه
اوديسا جنوبيه اوكرانيا وقد اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها تصدت للطائرات
الروسيه في سماء اوديس
جنوب البلاد وقالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت
مسيرات ملغمه على المقاطعه وتعاملت معها
دفاعات الجويه ما ادى الى سقوط الحطام على
عدد من المباني السكنيه وفد مراسل الجزيره
بسماع دوي انفجارات واندلاع حريق في احد
المباني بمدينه اوديس
اسقطنا ثمانيه طائرات حاولت مهاجمه منطقه
اوديسا ونتيجه لسقوط الحطام اندلع حريق في
احدى الشقق كما قتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصيب 26
نتيجه الانفجارات بينهم طفلان وامراه كما
اصيب ثلاثه اشخاص وتضررت بعض المباني
عندما دمرت قوتنا ساروخين حاول استهداف
ساحل المدينه العدو لا يحقق نجاحات في
الجبهه لذلك فهو يهاجم المناطق الخلفيه
اعلن حاكم شبه جزيره القرم ان منظومات
دفاع الجوي الروسيه اسقطت صاروخين
باليسيين اوكرانيين دون وقوع خسائر في
المقابل سلطات مدينه بولتا في شمال شرق
اوكرانيا ان مطار ميروغورود العسكري تعرض
لاضرار طفيفه اثراء هجوم روسي بصواريخ
باليسيا وطائرات مسيره الليله الماضيه
سنسال كارمن جو خضار الموجوده في
عن هذه الاستهدافات الروسيه
جنوبا وايضا عما تورده
او يورده الجانب الروسي بشان محطه
نعم حسن موضوع
والاستهداف بالطائرات المسيره التي
اسقطتها الدفاعات او التي اسقطتها القوات
الروسيه في محيط هذه المحطه نقل الى
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وقالت
وكاله تاس انه
الوكاله ستتابع مجريات هذا الامر وتفاصيل
هذا الامر المواقع الروسيه نشرت صورا
ثابته لهذه المسيرات ولكن ما جرى في محيط
الوكاله النوويه محطه النوويه بالاحرى
يوضع في اطار عام مرتبط بالمعارك المستعره
على عدد من الجبهات هذا الامر تحدث عنه
يوم امس الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الذي قال انه يقينا الهجوم المضاد من قبل
اوكرانيا قد بدا بالنسبه له هناك معطيان
اساسيان الاول مرتبط بالمعارك التي وصفها
بالطاحنه على عدد من المحور على عدد من
المحاور
مرتبط بمقاله انه استخدام من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه للسلاح الاستراتيجي والمخزون
الاستراتيجي من السلاح ارتباطا بالميدان
وهذه التصريحات اليوم هناك عدد من المواقع
العسكريه المواجهه بمتابعه تفاصيل الميدان
تحدثت عن هجمه اوكرانيه جديده فجر هذا
اليوم وليل امس تحدثت عن جبهه زبروجي وعدد
من الجبهات بروجيا تتبوا وتتصدر العناوين
في هذه المعطيات الميدانيه وهذه المواقع
افادت عن صد كل الهجمات التي قامت بها
القوات الاوكرانيه من جهه سافا تحدثت عن
خسائر فادحه في السلاح تحدثت عن دبابات
امريكيه بريطانيه لوبارتوت تشالنجر ابرامز
كلها دمرت نذكر انه في الايام الماضيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت كثيرا عن هذه
الجبهه جبهه زابوريجيا منذ الرابع من
حزيران يونيو بدات الهجمات في تلك المنطقه
ويوميا تنشر وزاره الدفاع عدد من المقاطع
المصوره التي تثبت الدمار الذي لحق بهذا
السلاح الغربي الذي تلقته اوكرانيا غربا
بوتين تحدث يوم امس عن ان هذه الهجمات لم
تستطع اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه وهناك
جبهات اخرى في دنياتك وغيرها يمكن القول
ان القتال ايضا مستعر فيها حسن